do people do that a lot with your stuff
they'll buy and flip yeah mostly with
the prints not not so with the original
you know what I see that too cuz those
Griselda fans they love buying and
flipping [__] man the the pray for Paris
joint that I did you know that print
went for 100 bucks and it's on eBay for
like three grand Jesus so you know it's
how many prints did you do well whenever
I do [__] with Wes it's you know it's
really up to him I mean in more
collaborative well it's really his
choice I have very say like very little
say in what he does you know at the at
the uh the first few [__] that we did
together it was it was an addition of
100 and then he quickly started doing
editions of 187 makes sense on brand so
you know and I think he it only recently
he started doing like
250 you know with the with the Virgil
stuff
with and then you for me but um yeah I
mean that that that piece was extremely
popular and you know it's going for you
know I mean so much more than what it
actually I wonder like when you and like
cuz cuz obviously Westside guns got so
much to do with like giving you exposure
yeah um do you like charge him if he
wants a piece like he wants Thurman
Thomas with an eye BR okay okay you know
I don't know yeah big bro he he pays um
you know I I my relationship with Wes is
is a unique one and I think at after the
first year you know we we did stuff
together I think it quickly became more
family based than anything it became
tighter than I had expected and you know
whenever we do [__] it's I we don't even
talk numbers you know he he'll text me
yo I I need this by yesterday I'm like
all right I'm on it and the numbers will
be you know we'll figure out the numbers
later with every with anybody else it's
it's different you know what I'm saying
cuz obviously Wes is you know my Dr Dre
I mean like that's like my you know he
put me up for sure and I'll always keep
that relationship like that because I
feel like I owe it to him to just you
know I mean whatever he needs he knows
I'm there so but yeah I mean it's crazy
how that that relationship even you know
came about like I said after that first
year painting I did that portrait of Pac
third eye thing cracked off and then
some of my homeboys who grew up with uh
Diddy's kids hit me up and they're like
yo you should do a portrait of Biggie
and we'll move it to puff so I did a
portrait of biggie I was at the time I
was living in Vegas I [__] drove four
hours just to drop that [__] off in hom
Hills at Diddy's crib wow so that was uh
you know a stamp of of approval so Diddy
bought the biggie painting it it it's a
little trickier than that you know what
I'm saying I actually never even met
Diddy a lot of people think it was like
that is it hung up at his house
somewhere yeah no for sure it's it's
it's hung in a studio in homie Hills oh
nice what the crazy [__] is that you
know I never met Diddy right but he has
posted that [__] painting so many
times I mean that that painting is hung
in the recording studio in his house
right A lot of people have recorded in
there so many people background and so
many pictures many people have posted my
painting on on Instagram I remember Joey
badass was like raving about it you know
um this one was kind of this is kind of
sentimental but when nipy was working on
Victory lap he there's a picture he
posted with him and puff side by side
and you see my biggie portrait in the
background and I was like damn I was
like I felt like my spirit was there a
little bit during that process um and I
never got to meet dude and I would have
loved to cuz you know that was one of my
well that's got to be one of your
paintings eventually you got to do the
nip one man oh well I I did a nipy
portrait a while back for uh the real
Street Fest oh I was hosting that yeah I
was um I it was it was like I had a a
friend who knew the people over at what
was it 1500 sound is that what it is or
1500 Sound Academy oh yeah yeah 1500 and
nothing guys yeah yeah and it's like
George piche and [__] so they had a
thing going on with like Fender and I
had did a a portrait nip to put on
display at their Booth so I had that
that was the only portra I did of him
but you know I'm not really big into
doing
um like dead celebrities I I really only
do that [__] if it's if if it the
opportunity makes sense if someone's
commissioning it I won't just I did that
already I did that so much early on that
I realized I didn't want to base my
identity off of painting dead
celebrities it's not I'm not I'm not no
you've got you've done like [__] Josh
Allen yeah you know that's that's on
West you know that's like Wes's Cur
curation and and what he wants but I
won't do that consciously I've only done
it a couple of times and and if I do it
that's because it it really means a lot
to me to do it you know I wanted to
build my career off of my own [__] I
wanted to build my my art career off of
uh an original style of work of versus
being you know oh that dude just paints
it's so easy celebrities D you see that
[__] all the time I'm not I think a lot
of people misconstrued me with other
artists like I'm not a IG artist if IG
disappear you still are going to be I'm
still going to be like you know it's
kind of like modeling right it's like
you could be an Instagram model but
could you like do print work yeah you
have an agent you know what I'm saying
it's different there's a lot of
[__] that don't exist in that
world but they exist on the social media
platform so if that [__] disappears it's
like a lot of these Tik tokers you know
a lot of these Tik Tok [__] had
to find a a path cuz when Tik Tok
started to fall off you know they they
had to do something so either they got
into music they got
definitely started doing a bunch of that